Trump's approach towards Russia has been one
of the most controversial parts of his short
time in office so far.
It seems that the new US president wants to
develop a new friendship with this old rival....
The thing is that this isn’t proving so
easy, and that’s because Beijing is standing
between them.
Russia, Putin, Moscow.
Without any doubt, one of the most controversial
issues is the fascination Trump seems to have
with Russia and its charismatic leader: Vladimir
Putin.
Insinuations, messages of support, the election
of senior officials who were close
to
the Kremlin…
The question is: Is Trump trying to seduce
the Russian leadership?
Or, as some are saying: Is there something
suspicious about this developing relationship?
It would be fair to say that Trump's approach
to Russia could have an explanation: According
to some analysts, advisers in the White House
may have told Trump to try to be remembered
and make history, by being the leader who
has the same success with Russian as Nixon
and Kissinger had with China.
NIXON SEDUCES MAO'S CHINA
On the 21st February 1972, one of the most
important events in decades took place.
That day, Richard Nixon arrived in Beijing.
It was the first ever visit to Communist China
by a U.S President.
That entire trip was broadcast around the
world on TV, and it was major news.
Millions of people held their breaths as they
saw Nixon descending the stairs of the Air
Force One and setting foot in China’s capital
city.
But before we continue, let´s go backwards
a bit more to see what this visit really meant.
What were the goals?
And how was it made possible?
We’re going to travel back in time to October
the 1st 1949.
That was the day that China was declared the
”People’s Republic of China”.
The communists led by Mao had won Chinese
Civil War and they took power of the country.
This new regime was now completely hostile
towards Washington DC.
In fact, only a year later, troops of the
Chinese army participated in the Korean War
to support Pyongyang's regime, therefore confronting
the US face to face.
As a result of this bitter and violent fight,
and its thousands casualties on each side,
there were no intentions of establishing any
diplomatic relations.
It would even be fair to say that from that
time on, China and the USA were enemies.
In the meantime, relations between Beijing
and Moscow were very different.
It is true that Mao had never got on with
the Soviet leaders, (who had, by the way,
supported other people to be the leader of
the Chinese Communist Party).
However, despite all these differences, a
Russian-Chinese alliance was almost inevitable.
On the one hand, the Soviet Union needed to
control, or at least influence the other great
communist power.
On the other hand, Mao´s China desperately
needed the USSR for economic, technological
and military support.
The support was so generous in fact, that
between the year 1954 and 1959, the USSR spent
7% of the government’s resources assisting
China.
Some even say that it was the largest technological
transfer in history.
Despite all of this, differences started to
emerge in almost every part of the relationship,
and the alliance got weaker and weaker until
it completely broke apart.
Relations were getting very tense.
First there was the assault of the USSR’s
embassy in Beijing in 1967, and then the first
armed encounter took place in 1969.
The
casualties were numerous during the fight,
and a few days later, the Soviets bombarded
Chinese troops deployed in the area.
The conflict didn´t go any further but, for
days, there was a feeling in the air that
this could be the start of a significant war.
Moscow even considered sending troops from
the Warsaw Pact countries, which Romania objected
to.
It is also said that to prevent a potential
nuclear attack by Russian, Nixon contacted
Moscow to make it perfectly clear that the
U.S would never accept something like that
happening under any circumstances...
In the end relations between the two communist
nations broke down completely.
At the time, both Nixon and his famous National
Security Adviser Henry Kissinger, decided
to use the famous saying and make it their
own:
“The enemy of my enemy, is my friend”
And once they’d said it, they started to
put it into action - two years later Nixon
was in Beijing.
Relations between the USA and China moved
on slowly.
In fact, it wasn't until 1979 with Jimmy Carter
in office that full relations with the nation
were established.
But the truth is that Nixon’s trip to China
made room for a period of successful relations
between the two nations.
In 1972, bilateral trade between the two nations
didn't even reach a billion dollars, today
the number is close to $600 billion.
The relations have been relatively friendly
and the US made a solid ally against the Soviet
Union during the Cold War.
And this, according to some analysts, is what
Trump is trying to achieve with Russia - to
reenact Nixon and Kissinger's strategy for
Beijing with Moscow.
That would explain the pro-Russian attitude
of the current President.
HOWEVER, things very much different now than
they were in 1969.
THE ROMANCE BETWEEN CHINA AND RUSSIA
Relations between China and Russia have started
to improve since the end of the 1980s with
some treaties and agreements being signed
here and there.
But it all changed when Xi Jinping came to
power in 2012.
SInce then, relations have advanced quickly.
Consider what was said in 2016 by one of the
major players in the Chinese government:
“The profundity and the level of coordination
between both countries has reached a level
we had never seen before" - Yang Jiechi
And Beijing seems to be certain about one
thing: An alliance between China and Russia
would be very powerful from any perspective.
Today, both countries are cooperating like
they never have before: in 2016 Russia became
the first Chinese oil supplier, an oil which
arrives by land.
This is something incredibly important for
China, since the US would be unable to block
its arrival in case of a conflict.
This is something the US can do for oil that
arrives by sea.
Also, both countries have started to conduct
joint military exercises, have created economical
and technological bonds, and have agreed to
carry out projects to build infrastructure
which will connect both countries.
So how about some examples...
Well, here are three:
First: Military exercises
Second: Economic bonds
Third: Infrastructure.
And for this one, what better example is there
than this…
But there is more.
These two countries have signed important
military agreements.
China has committed to spending billions of
dollars to buy some of the most modern equipment
the Russian army has, such as S-400 surface-to-air
missiles, and the most impressive of Russian
weaponry: the Sukhoi 35 fighter aircraft.
Just have a look at this massive aircraft...
Further to this there are also many economic,
political, monetary agreements…
All of this has led to quite a lot of concern
in the United States.
THREATS TO THE CHINESE-RUSSIAN AFFAIR
But just sit tight a second before we all
start to get scared because everything isn’t
quite as idyllic as it sounds.
Both powers may have come together, but there
are still many elements that separate them,
or might potentially weaken this unity.
For one, China wants to be important and influential
in international politics and that implies
becoming the leader of Central Asia.
This is something Russia certainly doesn’t
want.
In their view, the ex-soviets states in the
region have to remain under the influence
of Moscow.
Further, there are issues concerning their
economic relations.
The trade is unbalanced in favour of Russia
- Russia has become a supplier of natural
resources to China for the last few years
while China has been supplying Russia with
Chinese manufactured goods, which are more
valuable.
China´s position towards international trade
is very pragmatic: Chinese people want to
make money, so they know it is good for them
to open their market to the world.
This is an idea that Russia doesn’t share.
And then there is the issue with some of Russia’s
partners, like India.
Russia is the largest weapons supplier in
India, and obviously, Beijing doesn´t like
this at all...
So, even though these two countries are trying
to get closer and are supporting each other
against the US, we shouldn’t expect a very
solid relation between them.
After all, China is eventually going to try
to become the leader in this relationship
and Russia won’t just lay down and accept
that.
IS TRUMP’S PLAN A FEASIBLE ONE?
To be honest, it does not seem likely that
re-enacting Nixon’s strategy is possible.
This is largely because China is going to
strongly oppose this relationship.
But despite this, if Trump wants to earn the
trust of Moscow, he will have to make some
concessions which would be difficult to accept
in Washington: elimination of sanctions, giving
in on Ukraine and Syria, the end of the anti-missile
shield... among others.
Putin can be very demanding and even a good
relationship was established between Russia
and the United States, it is not clear whether
this alliance would even be very effective
at stopping China.
This is the reason why Obama preferred a strategy
of surrounding China by reaching agreements
with the country's neighbours: India, Vietnam,
Malaysia...
And in this strategy the TPP was key, and
I say "was" because it was one of the first
things Trump blocked when he arrived in the
White House…
Only time will tell how Trump’s strategy
works out, but right now, it’s not looking
very promising.
So, what do you think?
Will a Chinese-Russian alliance be consolidated
against the USA?
Or will Trump succeed in his Nixon-like relationship
restoration with Moscow?
Let us know in the comments below, and as
always do leave this video a like if you liked
it, and don’t forget to subscribe for brand
new videos every day of the week!
Thanks, and as always, I’ll see you next
time!